GILBERT STRANG: OK.
Now, I'm going to have
differential equations, systems
of equations, so there'll
be matrices and vectors,
using symmetric matrix.
They'll be second order.
So second order, second
derivative, that y
is the vector.
And S is the symmetric matrix.
And that's the first
time we've been
prepared for the most
fundamental equation
of physics, of mechanics,
oscillating springs--
so many applications--
rotating torques.
It's very important
in applications.
The finite element, giant
finite element codes,
are solving equations
like that all the time.
And we don't have a
damping term here, so
it-- or a forcing term,
so it's the null solutions
that I'm going to look for
to match initial conditions.
I don't have a forcing term.
OK.
So the real central equation
always looks like that.
This is-- Newton's law, is
what this is-- mass times
acceleration.
So M will be a matrix,
often a diagonal matrix,
telling me the masses.
Remember, I have
n equations here,
so I have n masses,
as you'll see.
And I have, let's say,
a bunch of springs
connecting those masses.
And then there's a matrix
K in multiplying y itself,
and that's always called
the stiffness matrix.
So, actually, in
applications, the first job
is to take the problem
and create these matrices.
I'll give you an example, but
let's suppose we've got them,
and how do we solve them?
We look for, as we always
do, solutions where time
is separate from the vector x.
I substitute that
into the equation,
So I get M, second derivative
will bring down the i omega,
twice.
E to the i omega t x, right?
Plus, this term, K times e to
the i omega t x, should be 0.
So I'm just substituting the
expected form for the solution.
In that form, that
exponential factor can cancel.
And, I see, I have an
eigenvalue problem.
Let me just look at
that eigenvalue problem.
I'm going to put that
on the opposite side.
But what i squared is
giving me minus one.
I'm just going to
be left with Kx.
Well, let me put this
on the other side,
because it's got a minus.
And then when I put it
over there, will be a plus.
M omega squared x.
That's an eigenvalue problem.
Here is the eigenvector.
There is the eigenvalue.
Oh, but we have two matrices.
That's something a little new.
Not new to MATLAB however.
The MATLAB command to
find these eigenvalues,
let me call those
eigenvalues lambda,
so lambda will now
be omega squared,
because two derivatives
brought down omega twice.
But we have our two matrices,
so the MATLAB command
would be i of K and M. If you
define the matrices, K and M,
and you call that command, it
will produce the eigenvalues
and the eigenvectors x
for this, you could say,
generalized eigenvalue problem,
two matrix eigenvalue problem.
It's got a K, as usual,
and then it has an M.
But many, many times, M will
be a multiple of the identity
and present no problem.
OK, so that-- this is
the eigenvalue problem
that we reached.
And that's the command
that would solve it.
OK.
That's the first step,
is to look for solutions
of that special form.
Now let's do a little count.
How many solutions
are we expecting?
How many initial
conditions do we have?
So we initially, we
give y at 0 of course,
the initial condition,
the position.
But we also give, in a
second order equation,
we also give the initial
velocity, y prime of 0.
And those are vectors,
because those tell us
the initial condition
of n masses.
And so I have n numbers from
y of 0 and n more numbers.
Two n, all together,
initial conditions.
I'm going to need
two n solutions.
two n solutions
to match two n
initial conditions
and solve the--
solve the equation.
OK, so what do they look like?
All right.
Here, I've gone ahead to
put an application up.
So, again, I'm taking
the masses to be equal.
Here are the masses, M, M, and
M. And so I end up with a 3
by 3 matrix.
I have three unknowns,
n is 3 for this problem.
And I've got 4 springs.
These are springs-- maybe I make
them look a little springier.
OK.
And they're connected at
the top to a fixed support
and at the bottom
to a fixed support
and they're connected
to each other.
Do you see what will happen?
As I, maybe I, the
initial condition,
I drag all those masses down?
As my initial
condition, I let go?
Then they will go up
and down, up and down,
just the way springs always do.
And they will solve,
their position
will be the solution to
my differential equation.
M y double prime
plus Ky equals 0.
So I'm not, I'm just
starting the motion,
and then backing off.
So I'm not forcing--
it's not forced motion.
It's pure oscillation,
pure oscillation.
Right.
But coupled, several
oscillators are
a couple, that's what's new.
We know all about this equation
when y is just a scalar, just
one equation.
We know that, and that led us
to the square root of K over M.
That was just a 1 by
1 eigenvalue problem,
and now we will have a 3
by 3 eigenvalue problem.
The mass matrix is simple.
Here's what the stiffness
matrix would look like,
if all those springs
were the same.
Just, I wanted to see
what kind of a matrix
shows up in the problem.
And time to write
down solutions.
OK, so what are we
remembering from solutions?
We're remembering that
solutions look like this.
I have, but I'll have three
possible eigenvectors,
because I have 3 by 3 matrices.
So that will give
me three solutions.
But I want six because I have
six initial conditions all
together.
Let me write those
six solutions down.
Y, the solution is, sub constant
times the cosine of omega t,
times the first eigenvector.
And another constant
times the sine of omega
t, times the second
eigenvector--
times the first
eigenvector, sorry.
The first eigenvector, I
have three eigenvectors,
and for each of them, I get
two solutions, one a cosine
and one a sine.
And the frequencies,
there would be omega 1,
and you are remembering
that lambda,
lambda is omega squared.
So if I write
omega 1 there, it's
the square root of lambda 1.
That's the square
root of lambda 1.
So I've got two
solutions so far,
coming from the first
eigenvector at its eigenvalue,
and with the cosine and a sine.
And then, I'll also have
for the A2 and a B2,
and an A3 and a B3.
So I just, briefly, A2, B2 with
omega, using omega 2 and x2.
And then they'll be
an A3 and a B3 using
omega 3 and the eigenvector x3.
That's pretty stupid looking.
This is what I
meant to represent.
I don't want to rewrite all that
with 2's, and then rewrite it
again with 3's.
That's what the
solution looks like.
OK.
How do we-- when we match
the initial condition,
what happens?
I said t equals 0, right?
When I said t equals
0, the sines disappear.
So it's the A's
that match y of 0.
So A's match y of 0.
And when I look at the initial
velocity, the derivative,
the derivative of the cosine
is the sine, and it's 0.
But the derivative of the
sine is the cosine and it's 1,
so I'll see that the
B's match y prime of 0.
I'm trying to get the
total count to be six.
So there are three,
three initial positions,
and three A's.
There are three
initial velocities,
cause there are three masses,
and there are three B's.
I get a perfect
match, a total of six.
Six constants, six
numbers to match.
It all works.
OK.
Now, do I want to
try an example?
Sure.
Let me end with a
particular example.
I better go to 2 by
2 for an example.
So can I do the
same problem 2 by 2?
So my problem is going to
be y double prime plus S--
there's a K, there's
a division by m,
and there's a 2, 2 minus
1, minus 1 y equals 0.
That's my equation.
Now, I'm speaking
now, about the problem
with a spring, a first mass
m, a spring, the second mass
m, and a spring.
So two masses, two equal
masses, three equal springs.
That's my equation.
So what's a solution?
How do I solve it?
I need the eigenvalues and
the eigenvectors of my matrix.
So here's my matrix S. That's
my matrix S. It's symmetric,
it's got physical
constants there.
The stiffness of
the springs divided
by the masses, k over m, we're
expecting that same k over m
that always shows up.
And we need the
eigenvectors there.
And what are they?
The eigenvalues of that
are 1 times k over m,
And 3 times k over m.
Cause the trace is 4.
2 plus 2 is 4.
The determinant is 3.
4 minus 1 is 3.
Those are the two eigenvalues.
And these are the omega
squareds, remember.
OK.
That's how I start
the system from rest.
So physically I pull
down these masses,
or maybe I push that one
up and pull that one down,
whatever I like.
I hold them for a
moment and I let go.
I don't give them
an initial velocity.
They start from rest,
so the B's will be 0.
So y prime of 0, y prime of
0 is going to be 0 from rest.
And that will give me B's are 0.
So my solution will
be, my A cosine of,
so the eigenvalues cosine,
I take the square root of k
over m t times the
first eigenvector--
one of the eigenvectors.
The eigenvectors of
this, probably are 1, 1.
And then the other
eigenvector, and that
will have a cosine of
the square root of omega,
I have to take the
square root of that,
so that's the square
root of 3, k over m t,
times its eigenvector,
which I think is 1 minus 1.
It's going to be
perpendicular to that one.
I've solved the problem.
The A1 and the A2 are determined
by the initial condition.
Now do you see what's
happening in the motion?
That's the last thing,
last point for this video.
This motion with a 1, 1
eigenvector, the two masses
are in sync.
They're growing
together, up and down.
That's one eigenvector
of the problem.
And it has a certain
frequency that they
go up and down-- a square root
of k over m, our old friend.
But also, with two masses,
they can go against each other,
like this motion.
That's coming from
this eigenvector,
and it happens at
a higher frequency.
So those are going--
the final solution
is a combination of the
masses moving together
at a little slower oscillation,
and the masses moving
opposite each other at
a faster oscillation.
Some combination of those
two is the solution.
And then if we had
three masses, there
would be three oscillations.
One where all three
are going together,
one where the outside
ones are opposite,
and one where all three
are, I see opposite signs.
It's a beautiful subject.
Highly developed, and highly
important applications.
But that's the nicest
solution you could hope for.
OK that's a second
order system, solved.
Good.